herzlich konsole leute wir sind heute
auf einem geheimen parkhaus dach in köln
und heute gibt es ein ganz besonderes
video wir haben schon gesehen haben
werden heute hätten wir den fiat
multipla beziehungsweise 22
[Musik]
die besitzer sind michaels geht
irgendwie größer
servus und hier habt sicher wie ich
viele fragen und wir einfach direkt an
erste frage warum multiplayer weil es
einfach das atemberaubendste der welt
ist muss war versagen vom designer habe
ich noch nie was schöneres gesehen
es ist hat charakter sehr einfach etwas
besonderes und irgendwie so ein
gegenstück zu diesen normalen karten die
man sonst ja und auf jeden fall was
besonderes also es gibt ja auch durchaus
kritische stimmen zum multiplayer ja ich
habe irgendwas gelesen jetzt ist also
ich habe mir war es noch nicht so
geläufig aber
zugeben das hier ist wie in manchen
fachkreisen so ein objekt der
kontroverse hier diese lippe die bulls
oder eine plastik kann man auch
dazusagen
die wohl sky also das ganze ist ja quasi
eine tiefere botschaft ihr habt ja so ne
hier michael
hepp ihr habt eine internetseite hatte
können auch mal abstecken auf
irgendwelchen multipla und das ist ja
ein projekt über das auto hinaus geht
eigentlich also das auto ist eine
botschaft dass die botschaft er nahm
aber an sich sind wir schon so eine
leiste community mit absolut verrückten
anhängern die alle dieselbe schraube
locker haben die wieder quasi naja alles
finde ich auch schon richtig geil im
endeffekt geht es darum sobald du auf
der straße in multiple sie's dann kommst
du dich davor und flex davor als wäre es
die geilste karre auf der iss
dieses sich selbst dabei nicht so ganz
so ernst zu nehmen und so einfach das zu
machen worauf er bock hat warum geht
deshalb haben wir uns die beiden auch
geholt um diese messe ist einfach rüber
zu bringen killer das finde ich nämlich
eine sehr gute einstellung leute also
losgelöst davon ist der multiple jetzt
so technisch und designmäßig ohne die
botschaft dahinter nicht um den
klassenbesten
das kann man schon sagen aber es ist
schon sehr sehr geil mit kombiniert mit
dieser botschaft das finde ich richtig
cool weil wir alle kennen diese leute
wie kann man warum gehen heute übrigens
hier
denn 50 und das kennzeichen turbo gerade
mal 23
wer gekommen bin also muss ehrlich sagen
heutzutage ist schon krass mit instagram
und alles leute sind so krank am flexen
absolut und alle wollen sich nur
darstellen und es ist schon sehr sehr
crazy deswegen finde ich das ist ein
sehr geiles gegen state man ja das ist
halt so eine gegenreaktion einfach kein
player heutzutage da ist nimmt so ein
bisschen die seriosität daraus und so
die sich selber immer ein bisschen nicht
so ernst zu nehmen das ist einfach das
was aber das eigentlich das auch genau
mein ding das so ein bisschen manchmal
fühle ich mich auch wie so ein kleines
schweinchen und denk mir jetzt muss ich
mir ein bisschen über das macht
umzugehen und
jeder ja auf jeden fall also ich würde
selbst multipler fahren leute gucken
schon mal hier reinkommt wir haben
nochmal auch besonders bei multipler
sechs einzelsitze aber diesen einzelne
diesen nicht verbunden
einzelsitze hinten
wie vorne dreien komplett absurd das
sitzkonzept hier die
haltegriffe oder oder sind die wird
jedes um die tür aufzumachen für trifft
genau von innen und hier
damit die kleinen kann ja eigentlich
auch ich habe es wichtig
zu wissen was auch sagen diese kombi aus
nachbarstaaten radkappen
ja da war irgendwas mal mit dem
vorbesitzer mit dem kofferraum
neuer kofferraum her und der hat dann
auch nicht mehr den schriftzug hier
vorne das hat aber dann der andere
wiederum sind ja der hat nicht aufgehört
da ja ist erst auch heiß begehrt also
ich sags mal so leute ich hab mal gesagt
so zwei arten von autos kann könnte ich
mir vorstellen zu fahren entweder man
nimmt das auto thema ernst macht sich
wirklich kopflose was geiles oder
mannschaft komplett trauer das ist so
die zwei sagen ich bin mir sehr wir
gucken mal auf der anderen seite da sind
nämlich für andere
übrigens aber leute ferrari blinker ja
sicher die blinker ist das geil das noch
richtig authentisch
es gibt aber viele
klatschen bisschen genauer konzert ist
tatsächlich so gedacht dass die
möglichkeit auf geht ja aber keinen
schaden an ok im wege dürfen wir
ja schlau das ist ein city fahrzeug
eigentlich gedacht ja möglichst viel
platz auf möglichst wenig raum zu
verbrauchen um möglichst viele sachen
oder personen in dem fall zu
transportieren und ja das ist eigentlich
der der grundgedanke der in dem
multiplayer eigentlich komplett von
vorne bis hinten eben durch gedacht ist
und das ist total geil wirklich ja also
das dass das segment von außen ich will
mir das design sagt denken sie was soll
das aber es hat tatsächlich alles einen
sinn und das ist erst mal kapieren ja
quasi also nochmals ein wissen das ist
sehr ist ultra kompakt also das ist
jetzt umso länger oder drei meter 97
oder so was also wie ein golf golf 4
format golf 4 4 traf golf 4 format und
22 breite okay dass ich ein bisschen
breiter und das ist wie in einer
oberklasselimousine
[Gelächter]
und das ist so quasi in der klasse
einzigartig es gibt kein vergleichbares
fahrzeug was solche werten ist auch
eigentlich der grund dafür ist dass
damals viert mit renault und noch ein
paar anderen ein vertrag hatte dass sie
eben kein auto bauen dürfen bei uns
länger als vier meter ist und sechs
sitze hat und dann ist der designer und
auf die idee gekommen hier ich kriege
das hin im unter vier metern die sechs
heats unterzubringen und dass das
resultat also alles läuft darauf hinaus
kompakt und möglichst wie bloody sein
dass gutes stichwort weil ihr seid mit
dem roberto rossellini in kontakt sogar
selbst also wir dann auch egal ich fahre
auch einstellung auf jeden fall nicht zu
ernst wenn ich schon geil oder diese
kennzeichenhalter also
ohne kontext
sie mussten auch sein also extra von
irgendwas ist ja flexibel ja geil also
werden noch welche möchte für seinen
eigenen multiple in multiple
sich gerne welche über uns bestellen ja
auf jeden fall äußerlich an der
beschreibung wie
gucken was es noch gibt ich komme da
wirklich
[Musik]
war damals die erste idee alle drei
leuchten oben einzubauen aber so ein
paar test gemacht oder kann festgestellt
dass man im leben einfach nichts mehr
sieht aus also eine lichtstarke dann
mussten sie nach unten wenn sie die
nebelschlussleuchte hier machen
das wäre alles nach front ne war es dann
so weit oben ist sich sollte die straße
nicht gehabt dann aber nix aber es hat
ein bisschen of reggae vibes für ballack
33 hast ja auch genau die leute bevor
ich es vergessen 100 ps 100
das weiß ich nicht mehr genau ja
ich glaube ist ein sauger glaub ich
schon mal ins innere leute kommen
die tür arbeitet auch er gibt immer
akustische signal
hinterher
hatte julito recht voll durchgezogen das
ist komplett durchgedreht
ja alles ist rund und das ist alles so
ein bisschen auf möglichst
platz zu sparen alles an modulen ist da
in der mitte für eingebaut hat dieser
lüfter allein das nennt man in
fachkreisen auch das alien ding
also dass jetzt das alien ding ja genau
was und münster da kannst du noch park
tickets reinstecken der reihe ja also
wenn wir 20 münzen in unterschiedlichen
größen hast ganz entspannt sich aber
auch so wichtige goldmünzen der
weg unter ja dann halt die
newcomer gut wusste auch seien
legal zugleich ja ja noch das ist so
absurd
und ich sage da genau ja und fürs
sportliche fahnen wurde das dashboard
aus sondern ist zum fahrer auch bewegten
das hat auch noch eine geschichte der
sticker also country front sieht auch
frisch das ist eigentlich die die
geschichte dahinter ist dass den
multiplen zwei varianten gern auch
wieder mit den drei sitzen vorne oder
optional halten kühlschrank in der mitte
zu haben
und übrigens hand
genau links andere seite
hat keinen platz mehr gefunden im
kühlschrank oder klar wegen der wegen
sitzt ne hammer ja was wird er sagen
wahrscheinlich mit mit grill und 50 oder
kann man machen wie man will köln frauen
danach genau das was sonntag machen
also vorsicht der mit jetzt krassen okay
[Gelächter]
aber für mein schöner berg gerufen
geil
2003 jahr übrigens heute die beiden
jahre alt sehr geil also gerade liegl
sehr gut das kann man nur sagen bevor
fahren sind auch nicht eure erste autos
also hobby projekt autos dann auch genau
und ich bin alltag fast entspannt das
gerne auch und das ist wie ein bisschen
andere art von sportwagen als als hobby
sowie anderen sportwagen haben ob wir
das genau richtig also das ist ja auch
wir sind lange schon miteinander
befreundet es ist einfach ein tolles
hobby das man so was uns vereint so und
dann kann man auch mal sagen auf den
sonntag oder so trifft man sich mit
multiplen bisschen geld gucken so was
die anderen zu gucken haben wenn wir
vorbeifahren ja so ist halt auch
ziemlich geil die reaktion im menschen
wird wenn ich wieder angeguckt lankas
das schöne ist eigentlich dass alle
lachen erst die einen die denken
sichtbar was ist das für eine scheiße so
und lachen dich so ein bisschen aus und
wenn du willst egal
und die anderen die lachen somit gehen
die schreiben sich einfach das auto zu
sehen und irgendwo irgend wo fängt das
dann auch an spaß zu machen gesagt sind
die leute gucken hat ganz anders als auf
so eine sportklasse weil er jetzt
einfach herum fest dann gucke nicht
allein heißt jetzt geboren so wie
eigentlich erzählt er damit genau das
was alle anderen anziehen wollen ja nur
halt anders ja ja ja aber
es ist natürlich so wenn du mein verein
durch wird keine festen guck mich die
leute an als hätte gerade ihre mutter
beleidigt ist das so naja ok ich übe und
hier ist entspannt und
das ist ja auch wissen einfach so ist
fußball sagte ok leute dann springen wir
jetzt
nicht weiter dritter so würde da sind
wir im moment
[Musik]
ist das ein komisches bild oder das ein
komisches b3 man in der ersten reihe
übrigens da müssen wir mal direkt darauf
eingehen also wirklich wenn du denkst es
kann nicht dollar kommen dollar
er ist sehr wichtig
aber gut an daher fühlt sich jetzt nicht
wahr ist nicht ausgelutscht und
er hat über
180000 klasse der handbremse jedes
kleine handbremse an bremse ist
[Gelächter]
okay leute des cobo hall sophie mutter
anja günther weich die schaltung wird
das ist wirklich gut da weil ich
vergeigt
das ist einfach zu kranken hast jetzt
machen wir fangen jetzt direkt mal die
ringe runter
holen wir direkt mal alle blick gehabt
wechseln wir auf die schiene
und es gut ist wenn man nämlich viele
jungs trifft leute dann hat man immer
noch platz für zwei mädels nach dem club
oder jungs nie hat er ja gut ja gerade
hier auf dem ring ja dann auch die eine
oder andere verhaften
ich muss kann mich daran erinnern wir
sitzen im geld also wir haben wir haben
orange radkappen
[Gelächter]
gucken wir schon
[Musik]
alle gucken ist dass kranke gut man muss
auch sagen ich sehe halt auch in dem
auto wirklich viele italienische mamis
durch turin fahren oder so und ob die
jetzt besonders lieblich und sanft mit
dem motor im king das höre ich jetzt
auch nicht kannst du alles licht
anmachen dann siehst du das einmal
drehen an dem linken hier genau
guck mal
com heute jetzt auswahl netz ohne
beleuchtung fresh easy so super ist
jetzt einmal einmal tunnel
durch den tunnel wir lassen ja ein
bisschen abstand damit nämlich drauf
fahren
kann ich krieg da machen die
leute heute
[Gelächter]
richtig rein gedrückten sitzen
vorher gekauft
faust drauf auf jeden fall danke michael
micha fehler muss mitmachen gerne lernt
ja sozusagen
eine bewertung die gleichen